en la economía IA.
Además, conciencia individual de privacidad y propiedad de datos
está creciendo rapidamente
así convertimos la conciencia de este monstruo que soltamos en nuestro bolsillo.
Soy una madre de dos chicas preadolecentes
y créanme,
la única gran fuente de estrés y ansiedad como madre,
para mí, es la relación de mis hijas con la technología.
Este es un acuerdo de tres páginas que mi esposo y yo les hicimos firmar
antes de recibir su primer teléfono celular.
(Risas)
Queremos ayudarlas a convertirse
en ciudadanas digitales,
pero sólo si podemos hacerlas unas inteligentes y responsables.
Las ayudo a entender que clase de datos nunca deben ser compartidos
Si me buscas en Google,
De hecho -- lo siento-- si me buscas en DuckDuckGo
Tal vez encontrarás mucho sobre mí y mi trabajo,
pero tal vez no encontrarás información sobre mis hijas
Cuando ellas crezcan,
si quieren ponerse ahí, será su elección, no mía,
A pesar, insisto, de ser las más hermosas,
inteligentes y más extraordinarias niñas en el mundo, claro.
Y sé que muchas personas están teniendo conversaciones similares
y tomando decisiones similares,
Lo que me da la esperanza
de que un futuro inteligente rico en datos estará aquí pronto.
Pero quiero resaltar la cláusula 6 de este acuerdo.
Dice, "Nunca jamás, buscaré cualquier información en línea
si me va a resultar embarazoso, si lo ve la abuela Dawnie".
(Risas)
Inténtenlo. Es realmente efectivo.
A través de la historia
siempre ha existido una compensación entre libertad e igualdad
en la búsqueda de la prosperidad.
El mundo siempre se ha movido a través del círculo
de la acumulación de riqueza al de redistribución de riqueza.
Como la tensión entre los que tienen y los que no tienen
está irrumpiendo en muchos países,
está en el interés de todos,
incluyendo el de las grandes compañías de datos,
prevenir esta nueva forma de desigualdad.
Claro está que la propiedad individual de datos
no es ni perfecta ni la completa respuesta
para esta profunda y compleja pregunta
sobre qué es lo que hace a una buena sociedad digital.
Pero de acuerdo con McKinsey, la IA generará
USD 13 billones a la economía emergente en los próximos 10 años.
Los datos generados por los individuos sin duda contribuirán
a este enorme crecimiento.
Entonces, ¿no deberíamos al menos considerar un modelo económico
que empodere a la gente?
Y si los propietarios privados ayudaran a sacar a más de 850 millones de personas
de la pobreza,
es nuestro deber
y nuestra deuda con las futuras generaciones
crear una economía IA más inclusiva
que empodere a la gente además de en los negocios
Gracias.
(Aplausos)